yo tout le monde sait ce qu'ils y
ajouteront se retrouve une belle fois
avec l'oculus rif pour tester mon tout
premier jeu d'horreur en votre compagnie
c'est parti ah je vais le mettre tout de
suite pour faire donc un jeu de pont à
ces partis nous y sommes donc sur l'île
de ringer petit parapluie aux un café le
robot moonwalk
du très très lourd ce soir
ok bon s est quoi puiser dans la main
très bien je lance de l'eau ben voila
mais c'est parfait c'est ça qu'on veut
ok on y voit votre boxer ex imminent
waouh
tu vas apprendre à ouvrir moins
violemment un dorénavant l'important
hockey dans une petite maison beau
ok maintenant mais ce soit en boucle et
on danse
j
disponible sur itunes voici le lien ah
j'ai entendu du son a demandé à mon avis
oui voilà il faut qu'on purifie sais
mauvaise c'est moi mais ce fut mais
qu'ils soient en fait au pointage de ce
placard oh mon dieu elle est là tu as
parlé devant nous vite annoncée avec une
démarche de deux beaux gosses c'est un
battant mais qui a ça chez lui quoi mais
ça ça n'existe pas ça ça c'est juste pas
possible
ah tiens bois bois il est dit on dirait
juste que je fais pipi dessus mais bon
bois quand même qu'est ce qu'on a ici à
je voulais pas qu'elle s'ouvre
j'ai entendu du bruit wahou mêlée portel
t'agresse dans le jeu c'est un truc de
dingue ça me fait rire parce qu'en fait
dans le jeu je me vois cent fois trop
grand par la ville d'akbou moi mais ça
suffit
oh mon dieu un démon qu'il allait
rappeler toyas bhl est cette porte
franche sonnait sans déconner vraiment
elle me foute mal quoi c'est quoi ça ok
c'est pour danser de manière aux
mondieux une source démoniaque
par ubu2 bande ou hockey en bas ya
sûrement un max de monde
un max de jefferies démoniaque regardez
il faut une fête regardez je les vois
c'est mon piano je sais que tu es jaloux
du bit de thaler
je suis seule autorisée à danser là
dessus
oh mon dieu
ceci est interdit par la loi française à
la lumière qui saute c'est toi c'est toi
qui joue avec la lumière
non ne te cache pas sous le bureau
arrête c'est toi qui fais ça en fait
depuis saône et moi c'est pas qui je
suis alors y at il à mon dieu elle a
voulu se doucher or comment se fait ce
coup et tu jeune démon tu te cache
peut-être nulle part donc là on va
redescendre pour remonter pour
redescendre cent mille fois arrêté de
jouer
souad et romain bothet donc lui il vit
sur un nuage très bien ouais t'as un
watt
mais tout part en couille qu'est ce que
c'est que ça o une source ce démoniaque
ah non c'est une lampe c'est pas grave
allez on applique le lot bénite
on a désormais des oranges bénite oh mon
dieu le démon sur les toilettes
ah mais c'est de couper les attire lâche
pascal elle alors souri je sais pas ce
qu'elle fait mais as tu sais que tu es
coupable
bah oui tu es coupable ou pas oui allez
allez un épicier où joue abbaoui
quelqu'un joue du piano
j'arrive à ya des bruits partout
attendez
au bo [ __ ] tu m'as ses peurs à un
petit statut de l'ombre pourquoi ya des
bruits chelou la lumière odieux vite
appliquons du préparateur n'entretient
pas le droit donc je sais que tu as
envie c'est pour ça qu'ils se
manifestent mais nous y attaquer par de
la paix vaisselle salut tu me fais plus
cool hein hein tu me la fait plus bon vu
que tu as l'air gentil ok ça à ça suffit
pour la paix de john machine bah je ne
peux pas très bien si je fais une
machine je la fais tu me donnes pas
d'ordre ok ce que ces femmes ont eu le
dessus allez c'était moins le malin
maintenant arrêter de fermer les portes
c'est insupportable au y avait un truc à
quai c'est que ça quelque chose s'est
envolé y avait un mec là y avait une
sorte d'ombré et c'est ce qu'elle aux
toilettes pas du tout est ce qu'elle
fait est ce nom me dis pas qu'elle fait
ma machine à j'ai eu peur quand même
on va monter là-haut salut salut uns aux
autres est d'aller sous bureau
sévèrement au terrain à un jeune homme
il courait la ce bureau pour jouer à
world of warcraft toute la nuit arrête
de boguey sinon c'est le court circuit
quand ce fut bénie alors je retourne en
bas avec une bonne démarche de bûcheron
wata écarts n'ont plus d'électricité
saluant loges vas tu me protéger non
très bien je n'ai pas besoin des de
toute manière
mam est la mienne non ouais d'accord
donc si je comprends bien il est en
train de se nourrir de moi je comprends
bien il s'est nourri de moi et
maintenant nous sommes une petite boule
de feu mais oui comme toutes celles
qu'on d'achat c'est juste avant oui ceux
ci gagnent trompe pour des temps dans
leur bureau j'ai décidé de jouer à deux
google fn est en fait c'est un jeu où tu
joues un éléphant dont tu peut notamment
faire l'hélicoptère elle et quand un
hélicoptère c'est génial attention au
hockey ça c'est pas du tout passé comme
prévu donc le monde je crois c'est tout
casser voilà histoire de bien détendre
l'atmosphère un désolé ok écrasé par un
sapin c'est la terrible histoire de jean
paul edwards oh oui un match de foot
mais un plat à au revoir témoin le patro
pourrait lui les bons c'est qu'est ce
qui se passe dans le jeu hop hop hop sur
la reprise merde c'est un très gros
joueur alouettes
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est un géant
faisant de crise d'épilepsie c'est la
police est en état d'arrestation journée
d'échangés en europe la bid et ses
claques moga
j'aimerais pas être confisqué en haut
lieu alors là sa part carrément oui
suffixe la police la police regardez
leur tête là où nous venons en paix nous
aimons tvi 30 au
qu'est ce que c'est que ça à la ville
est plié en deux dans une feuille a4
je me fais attaquer par des boues le
bouc bizarre non pas but bizarre bull
blizzard a pas trahi qui la suivait les
fake qui à être trompés de 22 m et chez
paid to stop donc ça c'est un cactus
géants peu connue mais des cactus géants
ça n'a aucun sens quoi ça donne un non
sens au jeu quoi
toutefois tout était sens c'est pourquoi
les cactus ok d'accord je me l'indiquer
par départ des milliers l'effort
multicolores a été ludique un peu de
psychopathe
moi quand je trouve cette musique
généralement j'ai l'impression qu'un mec
qui me regardent comme ça à côté fabre
après j'espère quand même que c'est pas
le cas
thanks for playing bombers lyle gens
c'est déjà la fin de cette deuxième
petit faiseux sur le cul strip c'était
la première fois que je joue un jeu
d'horreur avec ça et bon c'était pas un
très grand je dors
il faut l'avouer c'est surtout qu'on a
vraiment l'impression d'être dans cette
[ __ ] faisceau donc ça fait peur croyez
moi si ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça me fera
plaisir sont donc très bientôt dans une
nouvelle vidéo
tu as tout le monde pis et n'oubliez pas
défoncer tout bon avec voteront pas
comme ça voilà et attend à venir cette
fois à moutier